tout de suite retrouvez l'actualité de
la semaine retour en images les
principaux événements du département
l'association des membres de l'ordre des
palmes académiques a remis le prix du
concours défense et illustration de la
langue française
vendredi 10 juin dans l'hémicycle du
palais de la source
nous avons la grande chance de surcroît
cette année d'avoir des lauréats
nationaux c'est à dire des gens qui ont
été reconnus par un jury national
je suis très très très tentés de de voir
là dedans à symbole du réel travail que
nous faisons à l'éducation nationale ici
trois prix ont été créés pour les
participants des écoles élémentaires des
collèges des lycées et des universités
il s'agit du prix d'expression écrite de
la langue française du prime aux
passants de la jeune nouvelle et du prix
de la jeune poésie c'est vraiment avec
beaucoup de satisfaction que on se rend
de plus en plus compte qu'on a des
pépites à l'île de la réunion et c'est
avec beaucoup de plaisir pour continuera
vraiment à les guider à les encadrer à
les amener vers l'excellence
depuis le début du mois des boîtes à
idées ont été installés dans les quatre
gares routières du réseau car jaune
les usagers peuvent s'informer à
l'accueil sur le tableau actualisé par
le chef de gare et depuis peu ils
peuvent aussi donner leur avis est à
l'écouté des gens la première des choses
et en même temps ça va les retrouver
si tout ce qui met en place satisfait la
clientèle on a des gens qui no qui ne
laisse pas passer
pourquoi le renseignement
le faire passer par une boîte à rêves
dépose mes remerciements les suggestions
ah oui c'est très positif ont fait des
offres très intéressant ces derniers
temps j'ai avec moi la carte réunis
parce qu'ils aient eu un titre de
transport intéropérables valade que tous
les réseaux de transport
vous savez qu'on a mis en place la wifi
dans les réseau car jaune
donc voilà deux exemples concrets
d'amélioration des offres de services et
nous attendons de la population des
usagers qui nous donne aussi des idées
pour pouvoir améliorer leur voyage en
fait
le conseil départemental en partenariat
avec le cnfpt a organisé une journée
d'actualité sur la nouvelle loi relative
à la protection de l'enfance
lundi 13 juin dans l'hémicycle du palais
de la source en fait la loi de 2016 et
on va dire compléter et renforcer la loi
2007 dès qu'elle réaffirme aujourd'hui
le rôle fondamental du département de la
protection de l'enfance elle assiste sur
une meilleure identification des
problèmes un meilleur repérage des
risques mais également comment mieux
sécuriser l'année sur le parcours de
l'enfant
le deuxième point majeur et ceux du bien
et vit de la prévention comment
renforcer l'accompagnement en amour des
familles car en sorte de proposer des
mesures alternatives dans le cadre
administratif dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement des familles avant
d'arriver à un placement judiciaire elle
troisième point et celui la place de la
santé donc la loi insiste beaucoup sur
la nécessité d'avoir un médecin référant
au niveau de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
ce que j'attends donc de la loi de 2016
c'est que vraiment ils viennent donner
ou département des modalités donc
pratique pour pouvoir mettre en place et
en oeuvre des dispositions qui avait
déjà été validé par la loi de 2007 et
qui n'ont pas pu
la faute donc de décret est suffisamment
explicite être mise en place en fait par
le département
inauguration de la maison d'assistants
maternels café vanille à l'étang salé le
mercredi 15 juin en un site justement
les mamans à ouvrir les membres associés
regarde personne qui veulent travailler
parce que c'est quand même a mis un
super métier et individuellement petit
c'est plus compliqué mais en s'associant
ensemble c'est c'est peut-être plus
facile de faire aboutir un projet quand
il ya des réunions
there is no d'information on a suivi des
formations on a passé notre diplôme
premiers secours le ps sort avec une
capacité d'accueil de 16 enfants et une
demande très élevée cette 24e man
affiche déjà complet pour l'éveil des
enfants le
la même café vanille et quand même
intéressante parce que c'est un groupe
d'enfants qui est nombreux ils sont à 16
ans tous l'équipe fait des activités
régulièrement les enfants entre eux du
coup il ya des interactions
ça leur permet d'avoir plus de facilités
en termes d'embauché puisqu'elles vont
s'installer à un endroit où il ya de la
demande que le département a décidé
d'accompagner financièrement les
porteurs de projets mam notamment en
accordant une subvention de 4000 euros
par mam à gré est aussi de permettre aux
assistantes maternelles de pouvoir
solliciter un prêt ça permet de financer
les premiers travaux pour pouvoir
ensuite obtenir l'agrément de plus près
de 150 assistants maternels bénéficient
chaque année d'une formation gratuite
organisée et prise en charge par le
conseil général
le collège bourbon a participé à la
commémoration du centenaire de la
bataille de verdun pendant quatre jours
ils ont vécu sous les tentes à verdun
avec plus de 4000 jeunes français et
allemands dans la tente de la journée du
29 mai point d'orgue de cette
célébration une chorégraphie signée
volker schlondorff montrant des jeunes
fauchés par la mort devant l'ossuaire de
douaumont
nous avons proposé à un projet il ya
deux ans sur les poilus du collège
bourbon que nous allons proposer un
autre projet sur gallipoli donc
l'application des réunionnais dans la
campagne interne à nesle et lorsque le
projet d'envoyer une classe à verdun a
été connue le comité local du centenaire
nous a sélectionné quatre mille jeunes
qui se sont retrouvés autour d'un
programme pédagogique sur trois thèmes
majeurs comprendre la bataille de verdun
de 1916 comprendre la construction de
l'amitié franco-allemande et promouvoir
la citoyenneté la démocratie et la paix
y est on était vraiment dans des
conditions on a aussi une petite sacoche
et ça qu'est ce que les soldats portés
on a vu aussi dans dans l'ossuaire
plusieurs tombes de soldats morts et
inconnus français autre moment très
riche de ce voyage le recueillement sur
les tombes des poilus réunionnais tombés
pour la france et dont les corps sont
enterrés à verdun